Alex Trebek pays a tribute to jeopardy  champion at Sydney stole the 41 year old  science content developer from Austin  Texas died of stage 4 colon cancer on  December 5th before all of her episodes  aired appearing on our show was the  fulfillment of a lifelong ambition for  that lady from all of us here at  jeopardy our sincere condolences to her  family and her friends the show also  shared a video of Cyndi explaining her  jeopardy journey in her own words I'm  dying of cancer and I really would like  the money that I went to used to help  others and so this seems like a good  opportunity Cyndi donated her winnings  which totaled over $100,000 to cancer  research  you  [Music]